smash or pass so offensive
how could you just objectify people like
that they have feeling how are you going
to react if you meet them all these
beautiful doing smash or past challenges
something I would never do I am NOT a
hyper cried
tella mainly does it matter even if you
have that language barrier you got it
right
I thought I was going to react to the
smash or pass challenge to shame that
they know that I know what they did I
just want to know if they want to smash
know if they're interested or not here
we go number one beauty class 35 would
you would you smash these matches are
please are you I've been wanting to tap
that for so long please please for the
love of God say yes please oh no not
believe you yeah why why at least why
look at that big really yes
look at the bed what you don't go too
far I know but you know I need to learn
subscribe deceive it can't go back mom
what I think it's sad once - thanks look
at that face you told me right now
inside that's the smashed face I can
tell a smash fake from miles away
holy [ __ ] come buddy short gamers dad is
a homo
[Music]
I'm definitely gonna you're gonna bother
all right okay
sand I'm just sad it makes me sand
okay what about jacksepticeye would she
if she smashes Jack I'm gonna cry
forever
yeah fat design at least will be fun
what are you making fun why why don't we
never got grenades just I don't think
with it I don't even get the loan
roasting the man the myth the legend oh
my girl Sydney is really tired I like
him I'm early candies funny any smart
three guys more I probably I'll give us
a feeling Oh does it be too busy driving
I'm getting there hey look at that face
Thanks she wants it
did you hear that did you hear that in
this beautiful woman
we like to smash given a montano is that
a turn at a time
oh all right moving on getting hot in
here you're not you already were
laughing yeah yeah a lot of cleavage
going up let's watch yeah you I was a
live at you oh here's a good here come
on don't give a [ __ ] about all these
other people Jesus Christ us get to me
just get to me I don't care hey all
right hi beautiful
every dance on the picture that you
choose he kind of could you see yourself
cannot see what nothing like no it's
because yeah yeah come from me got a my
half year that I was in on
oh okay well moving on couples ones
they're always so awkward are they I
don't understand look at this guy
crossing his arms like I'm not into this
[ __ ] [ __ ] mean you better not say you
smashed that racist accent I just did an
accident I can't I can't tell anymore
Wall Street please god damn it oh god oh
god put it down - god damn never learn I
join cutie pie would be 410
whoa what yeah so that's it
five - what's happening so you got one
four five one four five one four ten a
room for a minute yeah so that's it
five ten okay going cutie pie will be
for ten hey hey hey don't go making that
face your meat boy that's the face you
make when your girl wants that Pootie
Act
Gabriel with oh man that's something
where that's beautiful feel awkward this
is is it really worth the views you
gotta question yourself when you're in
the relationship yes it's worth the
views moving on Thank You jelly for the
flattering picture you know I see I see
I see what are you doing here you're
you're scared you're scared ugly picture
pretty picture don't matter I know the
result cutie pie that was discretion
that currency with that little crowd and
pain well I know it was sweet it but I'm
not really into I do not say this like
no thank you
ah ah what what do you mean no thank you
I don't know how to say this but no
thank you
I pass I'm reminded now why I left
Sweden reminded now why I don't have a
Swedish girlfriend it's all coming back
now is it no coming back
I don't want to float my mom colic
please and you know what I'm raising to
Hannah she's a racist she's a racist
that's why if she wasn't racist she
would have smashed the shell bird hell
yeah I smashed that 50 million
subscribers you just want me for my
mouth dude Harley what the hell man I
thought we had something last time we
met you know we hug for a longer time
than usual
I'm giving 50 million of my babies on
his face know what I mean one no I I
don't know what you mean grab them by
the cheek look at me let me see those
eyes Felix she was ours yeah but I smash
would be great we'd have a great time I
ain't gay though yeah yeah me neither
we bang okay Oh nah
do you smash your pass on beauty class
look at that face faintly look at that
face she's about to say D it word I do
you broke this beauty pot that hammer is
not going to go anywhere inside me get
your girlfriend away from me control
your girlfriend
please PewDiePie please get ready she's
coming
I felt except a little sincerity there
she's probably not gonna ask your
permission either so you can come out
Noah and smash it that's called rape not
funny probably gonna lose right now you
wonder why if you say no to this guy
you're a liar you're the guy who always
says Lila as you lie that's you Molly
oh my god please let's get to the point
get to the point
I had to watch through like a million
videos just to get to my part all right
okay Carly QT 5 s math okay I mean I
don't care whatever it's not a big deal
it it okay I think you are hot Oh Carly
no I don't want to so much don't like
adviser you did it with video know where
you fall you know what else is a small
your channel I don't know
see six realize this is such a weird
video to make like I don't know moving
on
do you mean by abstraction I love you
guys so much exactly I just knew step
off I love TV oh hey Tina
what ha ha ha ha I say everything in the
world people were closed dead about that
like I don't mind been saying it at all
like he was tweeted dude he's not even
from America he wasn't involved in
slavery or anything like that
god bless you you guys are cool
appreciate you you know that that one
actually means a lot more than become
someone Thank You massa five beauty five
I love a little bit boyfriend's face
every time like this [ __ ] why - dude
you're not gonna want this the pair of
paths don't make me sick ok well what's
the verdict ah nah what a big issue was
in the world yeah why'd you pass woman
no no you can't just say I'm not your
type I can adapt we care color do you
prefer I'll go cream
I'll go green like Jack if I have to I
don't care I have a girlfriend whatever
oh well here's the thing guys everyone
has six [ __ ] signs in their videos
it's like I'm going to make a Smasher
pass video ah but first I have to print
a paper that says smash and then I have
to print a paper that says pack the
torn of the sign it's that you both say
at the same time and then you hold out
the sign at the same time and then you
look at each other to see the result and
then for comedic effect you're like oh
you pick that and I think that if you're
just going to have the sign
you can just say smash or pass you don't
need a sign
how is this not obvious and why does it
why does it bother me so much
yeah don't bother with the side magic as
a little hop same here you don't have to
sign a little very handsome
this is good if you both have to sign
you can hold it up at the same time and
then you can be like oh wow you big dick
[ __ ] hell hey guys yes this is my
secondly by the way while I'm at it if
you got to do a Smasher pass at least I
had the [ __ ] picture just add the
picture just add it in the picture how
am I supposed to find myself Kevin looks
like you would be a lot of fun just add
a picture it'll take you two seconds of
editing welcome to smash your pots today
me and Jordi are gonna smash your past
youtubers yeah yeah so close okay when I
look at my the last one we got cow
frizzy what's that such what's that sign
you need a butt man your butt man the
goddamn Tom now and you don't even put
me in your Smasher pass [ __ ] you man how
dare you disgusting you get
who you think Oh No please please I
can't handle any more humiliation you're
a boyfriend and I have a lot in common
if you can tell please
I had to mute this section and we upload
the video because for using the Mortal
Kombat Theme for three seconds they
thought they needed all the money of
this video this has been smash or paths
with Kalles kaviar your favorite
youtuber please sponsor me that would be
great
hoping companies want to work with me
anymore I don't understand please
Kalles kaviar if you want to send me
some free caviar at least you know I'll
take it think about it call me this
email
brofist